drums on Cecilia well the the the drums
on Cecilia that's all
handmade people think that's a drum I
always thought it was a drum there's no
drum in there at all no drum I'll tell
you how that happened we were sitting
around um one night with uh maybe three
four people just you know having a smoke
and and hitting guitar
cases and playing you know whatever it
might have been 8 or 9 minutes that
piece and we were recording it on a a
kind of a portable recording device that
had a very high quality right and I
listen back to it and the first thing I
noticed is that something within the
nagra is causing the thing to have like
a
slapback so if you
go it
[Music]
goes what a sound